foreign
there you are we've been looking
everywhere Kevin said he hasn't heard
from you all night yes I've been sitting
in my office wallowing in my
hopelessness and eating the saddest food
known to mankind
ice cream oh my God he's Bridget Jones
okay well it's time to put that aside
and pull out whatever food you eat when
you're happy dry beans sure look we can
still stop John Kelly all we need is
some hard evidence oh he won't let us
anywhere near him or one Belize Plaza I
know which is why I've assembled a team
of powerful allies in the NYPD no that's
too risky how do you know they're not
loyal to John Kelly because these people
aren't loyal to anybody
[Music]
oh
I made a Suicide Squad hey I present to
you the suicide squad hang on there
genius you want us your enemies to help
you bring down commissioner Kelly you
guys consider me your enemy you're some
of my best friends we haven't talked to
you in like three years CJ wait yeah I'm
thinking of different guys oh Raymond
you came to me to ask for help shows how
much you've matured you know it all
shows how much you've matured you're
with a face no I know why you refer to
this as a Suicide Squad Peralta because
I already want to kill myself why don't
you wait a week you'll probably die of
old age the only way I'm gonna die is if
you touch me with one of your bony
fingers and drag me across the river
sticks you Reaper ah wonderful very
creative look John Kelly has to be
stopped he's spying on civilians it's
unconstitutional and it's wrong please
do you think any one of these jackals
cares about what's right or wrong oh see
sir there is good in every person that
wants to be known as for selfish reasons
why would you want that to be known
because I never missed CJ before and I
want to think that I'm cool it's working
I mean I love how you're taking over the
room you know I actually wouldn't mind
getting rid of John Kelly either that
guy makes up so many dumb rules he told
me I couldn't eat raw chicken and you
think a new commissioner he's already on
board so yes a new commissioner would
let you eat raw chicken for whatever
reason it's healthier it sure is Siege
and what do you hope to get out of this
Madeline let me guess revenge on Dorothy
for killing your sister I want the same
as you Raymond I think what John Kelly
is doing is terrible yes well said once
so we're all on board this is exciting
let's bring it in huh Suicide Squad on
three ready one two I don't touch other
dude's hands his hand is sticky oh that
might be me I ate a popsicle earlier
it's probably Madeline cockroaches
release a mucus like secretion you would
know about roaches you roach and three
suicide squads so this apartment will be
our base for the duration of the mission
thank you to the vulture for procuring
it they don't thank me to thank my boy
Billy he said the place is mine while
he's still in prison that's not what it
sounds like his only crime was planted a
kick-ass Music Festival are you friends
with the fire Festival Guy best friends
you got a bum rap you can learn about it
when my documentary comes out it points
all the blame where it clearly belongs
with the island people wow so many
levels of terrible there all right we
need to catch Kelly in the act of
illegally spying so here's the plan we
commit a fake crime so serious that he's
forced to deploy the stingray what kind
of crime we're gonna kidnap a cop but
not just any cop it needs to be someone
so high ranking that it sends shockwaves
through the system but not important
enough that their absence negatively
impacts the NYPD in any way
what do you guys thinking we're clearly
all looking at you oh God am I in charge
of the meeting dismissed dismissed no
you're getting kidnapped CJ Amy Charles
and I will be the kidnappers Captain
Holt is the driver here's how it'll go
down approaching the target all right
let's do this mask song actually scratch
that we're not gonna use ski masks we'll
use cool rubber masks oh we should be
the ladies of the First Wives Club I
call Keaton We're not gonna do First
Wives Club masks just because you can't
be Keaton grow up Jake no because they
don't exist and also yeah Keaton is
clearly the coolest one and I don't
think it's really fair that you just
called her but forget it we'll wear
scary gorilla masks approaching the
target okay let's do this mask
she goes to get his morning coffee we
will arrive and grab him he will pretend
to struggle just enough to attract
attention
I'm gonna write this down so I remember
my lines I can see that you already have
the word milk written on your hand I
know where this is going milk milk don't
do that too risky what if you leave DNA
evidence at the scene well luckily it's
a missing person's case so the lead
detective will be the vulture he will
arrive and no no no hold on Peralta you
forgot to say that I ride in on my
motorcycle okay the vulture who rode in
on his motorcycle Colby will take charge
and eliminate any evidence we left
behind there's nothing here make sure
the other people working with you are
your worst detectives I got just the
guys for you I mean they're real Duds I
wouldn't even trust this too to get
coffee from me you're hard tell them
where we're at Brooklyn you know you
guys take off all right I got this right
hey you come here you wanna tell me what
you saw tell you what I'd like to see
you're big stop I'm the one describing
the place well so it's not gonna be any
sex at all no the point is without any
good leads Kelly will give the order to
use the stingray an order that we will
record thanks to our very own Madeleine
wunch not possible Kelly won't tell me
anything
with me perhaps you can sneak in
disguised as an old leather chair will
you calm down she works at One Police
Plaza all you have to do is run into it
Mr Kelly oh Madeline
I thought you were an old leather
not gonna say that hey buddy you're
worse than the vulture anyways give him
a handshake pat on the back I heard your
app called a serial killer
Clues strikes again yes indeedy and
plant the buck and that's the plan that
is exactly how tomorrow's gonna go got
it so you do or you don't want me to
yield milk
[Music]
fine Eddie it's not Halloween you look
like they're from Fifty Shades of Gray
yeah I got them from a sex shot baby and
we're lucky to have them there were only
three left at least you're not wearing a
gift mask look there weren't a lot of
options it was a very awkward retail
interaction can we please just kidnap CJ
now
leave me alone leave me alone
you never get me alive
foreign
[Music]
hey can we stop and get a slushie
gobby ow
Captain Pembroke what do you have there
do you find your hair nice work let's
bag it let's get it to the lab
they have my hair I thought you put your
two Worst Guys on this these are my
worst guys I write the real dorks they
both wear glasses one of them's even a
woman oh you said you didn't trust them
to get coffee look if you can't tell
what coffee is code for by now then you
and I shouldn't be talking about this
Jake oh my God he put his best
detectives on the case hey my two best
detectives are stinky and boner and they
definitely know how to order coffee
extra cream wink wink guys stop fighting
we did it let's just chill and play some
Madden no one's playing Madden with you
CJ you know Peralta this is all your
fault a witness saw your face and now
there's a police catcher you've been
sent around please that doesn't even
look like me the only thing they got
right is my little curl and I can just
get rid of that shake you're right it's
worth the risk to keep it oh man I can't
believe this wild ride's over we've
changed so much you know when we started
out we were just Charles The Jock Amy
the rebel Captain silly pants takitaki
Rosa Terry the stoner and CJ the
ringleader I'm not sure you're nailing
these okay I smooth things over with
Madeline and she's agreed to rejoin the
suicide squad oh goody gum drops but do
we even need her what does she bring to
the table 30 years of police experience
I have 33. I earned a police combat
cross I have a medal of honor I own the
record for most arrests as a uniformed
officer in NYPD history you got me there
of course I never spent much time in
uniform because I was promoted to
detective after one month they're not
allowed to do that it's against the
rules it's also against the rules to let
a pile of worms wear a uniform and yet
here you stand if we ratchet up the
pressure on him we might get another
chance how do we ratchet up pressure
more than we already have by making him
believe that the kidnappers are serious
and that CJ is in real danger what if we
send Kelly a severed finger in a box no
way I need all my fingers how else am I
going to do the Hang tank sign nobody's
cutting off your fingers yourself